Now that we have created our project
and got the initial setup and imported our assets,
we're gonna transition into talking
about the landscape material creation.
Now, before we get into this,
each project's approach to creating a landscape
is going to be different.
You can use a different collection of methods,
all dependent on the workflows for your project.
Now, this particular example
that we're gonna be going over today
is gonna use this type of setup.
We're gonna have a procedural layout
based on the slope of the landscape
that will expose different materials,
that will expose different textures in our material
in order to highlight where different surfaces are.
We're going to also have textures
that are for close-up detail
and textures that are for far away detail
to help reduce tiling artifacts.
We're also gonna introduce hand painting,
but we're gonna do it
so that we can actually remove
the procedurally placed grass
so we have a little bit more control over where it is,
but more importantly, where it is not.
Finally, we're gonna add displacement to all of this
to really help our landscape's surface stand out
with Nanite and the new Nanite tessellation options.